willkommen zurück bei bild live an
diesem donnerstagvormittag mit dem
großen preis schock bei gas strom sprit
was hat die politik hier verbirgt wir
stellen die fünf unbequemsten fragen
jetzt hier bei bild live im studio zum
energie desaster und warten natürlich
auf die fünf wichtigsten antworten von
bildpolitik chef hans schäfer guten
morgen ja guten morgen ja es ist ein
thema das uns sehr beschäftigt denn wir
schauen und wie auch bange bange in
diesem winter hinein und wie gesagt fünf
unbequeme fragen wollen wir jetzt
stellen und wir wollen fünf klare
antworten ja no pressure von dir haben
zu diesem thema war der atomausstieg ein
historischer fehler also wir sehen eine
orgie an preiserhöhungen beim strom beim
gas beim öl und wenn man sich das alles
anschaut gerade beim thema strom höchste
preise aller zeiten dann war natürlich
der atomausstieg ein fehler keine frage
wären es noch sechs meiler die laufen
drei werden ende dieses jahres
abgestellt drei dann ende nächsten
jahres und wir wissen im ersten halbjahr
dieses jahres haben wir ungefähr zwölf
prozent des stroms aus kernenergie
bezogen plus 27 prozent aus kohle das
heißt 40 prozent kamen aus
konventionellen energieträgern
also aus kraftwerken das heißt wenn wir
das raus leben diesen strom zwölf
prozent weniger energie dann musste er
woanders herkommen und dann kommt er im
zweifel aus frankreich dass er auch
atomstrom oder er kommt aus polen und
das ist kohlestrom von daher
kernenergieausstieg ein fehler das war
der strom jetzt ganz schnell rüber zum
gas wichtigste frage aktuell warum wird
gerade so viel teurer gibt verschiedene
gründe zentral ist nach der korona krise
laufen die konjunkturen läuft die
wirtschaft wieder besser es gibt eine
deutlich stärkere nachfrage
dann gibt es aber auch eine gewisse
verknappung die wir sehen also es gibt
dann auch zu wenig angebot und das
beides zusammen führt dazu dass ein
preis steigt wir haben außerdem seit
jahresbeginn eine co2 abgabe auch beim
gaspreis das treibt den preis zusätzlich
und das sind drei komponenten dazu
führen dass gas deutlich teurer ist und
eigentlich so teuer wie nie zuvor hier
in europa zumindest auf dem markt
deswegen die drängende dritte frage
warum tag das kabinett nicht warum wird
nichts getan das ist bemerkenswert
werden eine bundestagswahl wieder in
woche 3 nach der bundestagswahl und drei
mal hat das k nett nicht getagt das hat
eigentlich in der 16-jährigen amtszeit
von angela merkel noch nie gegeben ganz
klar ist das ist nicht verständlich
warum nicht getagt wird wir haben
drängende probleme nicht nur beim thema
energie beispielsweise auch beim thema
migration wenn wir einmal nach osten
schauen und es ist deswegen komplett
unverständlich oder ich auch töricht
dass das kabinett nicht zusammenkommt
die regierung tut so als gäbe es keine
probleme in diesem land das ist falsch
wir haben dringende probleme und so
lange es keine neue regierung gibt muss
natürlich die alte regierung auch
gemeinsam zusammenkommen und tagen jetzt
hören wir im zusammenhang mit den vor
allen dingen steigenden gaspreise immer
wieder nord stream nord stream nord
stream was hat putin aktuell mit den
steigenden gaspreisen zu tun wie viel
schuld trägt er und wie viel schuld
trägt merkel weil sie möglicherweise
reingefallen ist auf gerd schröder ja da
gibt es einen blame game was gerade
läuft zwischen der eu beziehungsweise
teilen der eu und russland wladimir
putin der dax liegt nicht an mir dass
der gast preise dramatisch gestiegen ist
aber das ist nur die halbe wahrheit denn
natürlich könnte wladimir putin viel
mehr gas durch die leitungen
beispielsweise die den westlichen teil
europas mit gas versorgt und der durch
die ukraine führt schicken also mehr gas
durch diese leitung das will wladimir
putin nicht denn er möchte dass das gas
über die neue pipeline diese umstrittene
ostsee-pipeline nord stream 2 fließt und
das ist der druck hebel den er derzeit
hat er sagt ist doch kein problem nimmt
doch einfach nord stream zwei in betrieb
und dann wäre es kein problem mehr gas
zu bekommen und das würde den preis
senken ich sage das ist ein falscher weg
schickt doch einfach mehr gas durch die
bestehende leitungen durch die ukraine
wenn es für uns teuer wird kriegen
andere mehr in die taschen so kann man
das ganz platt formuliert nämlich die
politik man hat fast den eindruck freut
sich da vielleicht der ein oder andere
über diese preisexplosion also für den
finanzminister ist sind steigende preise
per sie etwas gutes denn auf jedes
produkt auf jede ware kommt die
mehrwertsteuer obendrauf mit 19 prozent
das heißt je teurer ohnehin eine ware
wird umso höher ist das was der
finanzminister noch abschöpfen kann olaf
scholz geht derzeit mit einem lächeln in
sein finanzministerium danke für fünf
klare antworten auf 5 unbequeme fragen
zum energie desaster dass wir aktuell
hier in deutschland in ganz europa
erleben vielen dank an bildpolitik chef
jan schäfer vielen herzlichen dank der
[Musik]